we inherit an economy
on the brink of a great depression
millions of people losing their jobs
literally their homes
but even more poorly losing hope there's
more than one way to deal with the
impact on a family
than what we're doing and we're going to
beat inflation it is really the number
one
economic issue that
faces the administration in the nation
yes what actions are you taking to
relieve the pain of families well we
have to ask them what are you actually
doing
what does it mean
well let's bring in our panel to talk
about that syndicated radio host hugh
hewitt kimberly strassel member of the
editorial board at the wall street
journal and jeff mason white house
correspondent for reuters welcome to all
of you today just for kicks i went to
gallup's polling that they do constantly
talking about what's the most important
issue facing the country and kim not
surprising today 35 percent of the
respondents have the economy at the top
of their list
the administration is scrambling on this
no matter what they try it seems at this
point
yeah the democrats spent the last week
talking endlessly about abortion clearly
hoping to change focus and get americans
minds on something else but those polls
show that this is a pervasive problem
now for them what's even more worrisome
is if you look at the numbers this week
uh what it really suggests is that we've
got soaring demand too few workers and
that we're now in what's called a wage
price cycle
where
companies have to spend more to get
workers to stay or come on
they then hike their prices
then workers demand yet higher wages and
up we go and if that's the case the
white house is really going to struggle
to do anything about this and then add
in that most of what it is doing in that
it's cutting back on energy supplies
and adding regulations that make
companies pull back this is the exact
opposite of what you need to be doing to
help yourself politically and
economically
so to the point of energy supplies i
want to play a little back and forth
involving secretary yellen and this gets
to domestic production
did fsoc consider the substantial risk
that is actually now materialized that
over regulation of the fossil energy
sector
ending keystone blocking lease sales on
federal lands constraining supply of
energy
has actually undermined financial
stability specifically historic
inflation and four dollars and 37 cents
a gallon gas
i think we owe that to
um the failure of our domestic industry
to ramp up production to price i don't
think that's what they say i think they
say they can't get approval
and hugh there's a lot of back and forth
on that there is uh the white house
calling out the oil companies as bad
guys as people are profiting off of you
know difficult circumstances and saying
that they aren't using domestic
production they're saying
this isn't something that happens
overnight we can't get approval for some
of these projects and there are major
investments involved where do you come
down on this well i come down that
secretary ellen actually made me draw
back and wonder when she said the
production companies are not willing to
produce this very day the administration
canceled oil and gas leases in alaska
last week they withdrew them in the gulf
of mexico of course we can go back to
keystone this is an anti-energy
administration and that of course as
kimberly just said increases pressure
energy markets are forward-looking and
so long as they see ahead of them
obstacles from every department
regulatory uh impediments from every
official with a pen and a bureaucratic
sense of mission they're not going to
produce i just can't actually believe
that janet yellen said it's the
producer's fault when joe biden is
throwing every obstacle in the way he
can of lowering gas prices well jeff
it's not just conservatives who have
critiques for this administration the
washington post not a right-leaning
publication says this for much of the
last year the biden administration
wrongly told the american public that
rising prices would be short-lived when
it became clear that inflation would not
come down on its own the white house
began a blame game one of its favorite
talking points is to pin inflation on
greedy corporations for hiking prices
too much that just doesn't add up that
is from the editorial board jeff
well and they're also citing the the
impact of the war in ukraine and the the
ongoing impact of the ongoing pandemic
but the washington post is certainly
right
to say that the administration last year
said that inflation would be transitory
it did not turn out to be that way i in
fact asked president biden a question
about that earlier this week after his
speech about inflation i said
you initially thought this was going to
be transitory that's not the case what
is your projection now and he didn't
want to give a projection and that's
probably because they just don't know
they they want it to come down obviously
it is not only an economic liability for
this president it is also a political
like a political liability uh going into
the to the november midterms okay let's
talk covet the white house was part of
this global covet conversation today
here's what the president said
about where we are
there's still so much left to do
this pandemic isn't over and with
thousands still dying every day
now is the time for us to act
all of us together
we all must do more we have called upon
the united states congress for 22 and a
half billion dollars in additional
emergency funding to battle covet
okay let me put up another number here
because this is important while they're
asking for that funding and saying this
is not over yet the american people who
are worried about covet in our situation
these numbers have steadily dropped
people worried about getting coveted
back in april 2020 we're at 69 percent
we're now at 17 so hugh how do you
convince uh the average american that we
need billions more dollars for something
that they seem like they may be coming
to term terms with as part of daily life
it cannot be done because the american
people don't believe it those who want
to be vaccinated and boosted are
vaccinated and boosted and they are
traveling and they are living their
ordinary lives a covid summit will do
nothing except add cliches to the
boosters they are trying to turn the
page away from the economy the united
states the american people are
over-covered and they're not going to go
back to covet and i think the
administration knows that but they got
to do something with the president that
doesn't let him wander around a
microphone in hand in an audience making
gaffes well and kim it is one of the
few topics that in all of the polling
he's not upside down he is on
immigration the border russia the
economy but he's starting to make gains
on kovid
that the american people are gaining
confidence in his ability to handle this
well that seems to be mostly a function
though of the fact that they're not
caring about it as much
which is your point i mean
that seems to be the main point of this
now look i think one of the problems the
administration has here is that to the
extent it focuses on cobit it does it in
a way that tends to really annoy a lot
of americans and that it's all focused
on mass mandates on airplanes other
things designed to lock people up take
away their freedoms uh when you look at
that polling what it shows here is that
americans now want to live with covid
and if the administration was smart it
would be continuing its efforts but on
things that had more to do with
therapeutics for instance
tests and other things that allow
americans to manage their day-to-day
lives with the pandemic alongside of it
rather than a disruption on a day-to-day
basis i want to make sure we get to the
supreme court and the efforts to get
additional protections for them here is
a breakdown of reaction to where we are
right now
the garland justice department is
nowhere in sight the attorney general
was quicker to pounce on concerned
parents
at school board meetings they put
barriers up in order to protect the
supreme court building this is what we
should do around the justice's home now
i think we can both respect first
amendment rights
and protect the sanctity of our justices
homes president biden you need to tell
your attorney general to go and do his
job and protect the citizens of the
united states of america ultimately sir
this falls on you
all right so jeff there is a federal law
that appears to be pretty clear in the
wording about what happens the fact that
it's against the law to go picket or
parade in front of a jurist home for the
intent of influencing their opinion
their decision
as we await the actual original official
opinion from the supreme court the doj
has taken a lot of heat for being
willing to step in on a number of other
things but not necessarily this what do
you make of what they've said so far
well i think this just represents the
fact that this is such a divisive issue
and it's it's
focused right now the republican side is
focused on these protests the democratic
side is focused on what that decision is
likely going to be based on the leaked
draft and it's it's divisive and there's
going to be pressure on both sides
shannon if i can also take one second to
go back to the previous discussion about
kovid
to kim's point the administration is
doing that which she said they should be
doing and that's why they're asking for
money the ask may be controversial
because it's a big number but they're
asking for billions of dollars so that
americans can have
vaccines can have tests and can have
therapeutics this fall
well uh we'll leave it there on all
those topics panel thank you very much
for your time hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now